uh you've mentioned that fdr
franklin d roosevelt is one of the great
leaders
in american history why is that franklin
roosevelt
had the power of empathy no leader
that i have ever studied or been around
or spent any time reading about
was able to connect with people who were
so different from himself
as franklin roosevelt he came from the
most elite family
he never had to work for a paycheck in
his life when he was president he was
still collecting an allowance from his
mom
i mean you couldn't be more elite than
franklin roosevelt
but he authentically connected this was
not
you know propaganda he was able to feel
the pain and
understand the lives of some of the most
destitute
americans in other parts of the country
it's interesting so through the
one of the hardest economic periods of
american history he was able to feel the
pain
he was able to the number of immigrants
i read oral histories from or who have
written themselves saul bella was one
example the great novelists who talk
about how
as immigrants to the us albello was a
russian jewish immigrant
he said growing up in chicago
politicians were all trying to steal
from us i didn't think any of them cared
until i heard fdr
and i knew he spoke to me uh and
and i think part of it was fdr really
tried to understand people that's the
first he was humble enough to try to do
that
but second he had a talent for that and
it's hard to know exactly what it was
but he had a talent for putting himself
imagining himself
in someone else's shoes
what uh stands out to you as uh
important i mean he said he was
he went to the great depression the so
the new deal
which some people criticize some people
see i mean
it's it's funny to look at some of these
policies and there are long
um ripple effects but
at the time it's some of the most uh
innovative policies
in the in the history of america you
could say they're ultimately not good
for america
but they're nevertheless hold within
them very rich
and important lessons but the new deal
obviously world war ii
of that entire process is there
something that stands out to you as a
particularly great moment
that made fdr yes i think
uh what fdr does from his first
100 days in office forward and this
begins with his fireside chats
is he helps americans to see that
they're all in it together
and that's by creating hope and creating
a sense of common suffering
and common mission it's not offering
simple solutions one of the lessons from
fdr is
if you want to bring people together
don't offer a simple solution
because as soon as i offer a simple
solution i have people for it and
against it
don't do that explain the problem frame
the problem
and then give people a mission so
roosevelt's first uh
radio address in march of 1933 the
banking system is collapsing
and we can't imagine it right banks were
closing and you couldn't get your money
out your life savings would be lost
right we can't imagine that happening in
our world today
he comes on the radio he takes five
minutes to explain how banking works
most people didn't understand how
banking worked right they don't actually
hold your money in a fault
they lend it out to someone else and
then he explains why
if you go and take your money out of the
bank and put it in your mattress you're
making it worse for yourself
he explains this uh and then he says i
don't he does
i don't have a solution but here's what
i want to do i'm going to send in
government
uh officers to examine the banks and
show you the books on the banks
and i want you to help me by going and
putting your money back in the banks
we're all going to do this together no
simple solution no ideological statement
but a sense of common mission let's go
out and do this together
when you read as i have so many of these
oral histories and memoirs for people
who lived through that period
many of them disagreed with some of his
policies many of them thought he was too
close to jews and they didn't like the
fact he had a woman in his cabinet and
all that
but they felt he cared and they felt
they were part of some common mission
and when they talk about their
experience fighting in world war ii
whether in europe or asia
it was that that prepared them they knew
what it meant to be an american
when they were over there uh so that to
me is a model of leadership
and i think that's as possible today as
it's ever been so you think it's
possible like
i was going to ask this again it may be
a very shallow
view but it feels like this country is
is more divided than it has been in uh
recent history
perhaps the social media and all those
kinds of things are
merely revealing the division as opposed
to creating the division
but is it possible to have a leader
that unites in the same way that fdr did
without
well we're living through a pandemic
this is already
yes so like i was going to say without
suffering but there's
this is economic suffering right huge
number of people have lost their job
so is it possible to have uh is there
one a hunger
is is there a possibility to have an fdr
style leader who unites
yes i think that is what president biden
is trying i'm not saying he i'm not
saying he'll he'll succeed but i think
that's what he's trying to do
the way you do this is you do not allow
yourself to be captured by your
opponents
in congress or somewhere else fdr had a
lot of opponents in congress he had a
lot of opponents in politics
governors and others who didn't like him
uh herbert hoover was still around
and still accusing fdr of being you know
a conspiratorist and all these other
things so
um you don't allow yourself to be
captured by the leaders of the other
side you go over their heads
to the people and so today the way to do
this
is to explain to people and empathize
with the suffering and dislocation and
difficulties they're dealing with
and show that you're trying to help them
not an easy solution
not a simple statement but here are some
things we can all do together
that's why i think infrastructure makes
a lot of sense it's what fdr invested
into
right fdr built hoover dam hoover dam
turned the lights on
for young lyndon johnson who grew up
outside of austin right
fdr was the one who invested in road
construction that was then continued by
dwight eisenhower by a republican with
the interstate highway system
right fdr invested through the wpa in
building thousands of schools in our
country
planting trees that's the kind of work
that can bring people together you don't
have to be a democrat or republican to
say you know what
we'd be a lot better off in my community
if we had better infrastructure today
i want to be a part of that or well
maybe i can get a job doing that maybe
my company
can benefit from that you bring people
together and that way it becomes a
common mission
even if we have different ideological
positions yeah it's funny i
i've uh when i first heard joe biden
i thought many i mean many years ago i
think he went for
president against obama that's correct
right
i before i heard him speak i really
liked him
but once i heard him speak i stopped i
started liking less and less
and it speaks to something interesting
where it's hard to put into words what
why you connect with people the empathy
that you mentioned in fdr
you have like these bad pardon the
french [ __ ] like teddy
roosevelt
that connect with you there's something
just powerful
and with joe biden i can't i i want to
really like him and like
there's something not quite there where
it feels like he doesn't
quite know my pain even though he
on paper is exactly you know he knows
the pain of the people and there's
something not connecting and it's it's
hard to explain it's hard to put into
words
and uh it makes me not
uh as a engineer and scientist it makes
me not feel good about like
presidencies because it makes me feel
like it's more
art than science it is an art and and i
think it's exactly an art for the
reasons you laid out it's aesthetic
it's about feeling it's about emotion
all the things that we can't engineer
we've tried for
centuries to engineer emotion we're
never going to do it don't try and i'm a
parent of teenagers
don't even try to explain emotion
but you hit on the key point in the key
challenge for biden he's got to find the
right words
yeah it's not finding the words to
[ __ ] people
yeah it's finding the words to help
express we've all felt empowered and
felt good when someone
uses words that put into words what
we're feeling yeah
that's what he needs that's the job of a
leader and there's certain words
i haven't heard many politicians use
those words but there's certain words
that like
make you forget that uh that you're for
immigration or against immigration make
you forget whether you're four wars and
against wars
if you forget about like the the
bickering and
somehow like uh inspire you like elevate
you to believe in the greatness that
this country could be
yes in that same way like the reason i
moved to austin
is funny to say is like i just heard
words from people from friends
where they're excited by the possibility
of the future here i wasn't thinking
like what's the right thing to do
what's like strategic because i want to
launch a business
there's a lot of arguments with san
francisco or maybe staying in boston in
my case
but there's this excitement that
that was beyond reason that was
emotional yes yes and that that's that's
what it seems like that's what
builds that's what great leaders do but
that's what builds countries that's what
build grades
great businesses that's right and it's
what people say about austin for example
all the time
a talented people who come here like
yourself and here's the interesting
thing no one person creates that
the words emerge and part of what fdr
understood
is you've got to find the words out
there and use them yeah you don't have
to be
the creator of them right just as the
great painter doesn't
invent the painting they're taking
things from others
you